how long have you been trying to get
this film made in a traditional manner
before you went to fund anything it goes
through so
many steps i think you know you have an
idea i wrote a script really fast i
wrote the script really fast which is
actually not this particular script but
it was the original script of how i
started
and i wanted to write a comedy and i
thought if i write a comedy it'll be
really easy
and you know wrong so
i think there's a question of
it's a big process trying to find money
because it's everyone
who wants to give you money has an
opinion about a script as they should
because
they're giving you money and um
so there's that and then i don't know
people like it they don't like it i was
living in a different country i had to
come to america i'd come to los angeles
to kind of focus
on that so that was like even a year
after of trying to kind of have meetings
and go back and forth and
i mean my last home took four years to
be able to make and
it's it's not an uncommon story among
around filmmakers um so this has been
a couple of years but then i did a
really big script change
and which i think is way better it's not
a comedy anymore it's kind of a
movie about something it's got funny
parts in it but it's not
comedy and so
you know i i was thinking about this too
and i was thinking about how great
crowd how a great idea and effective
crowdfunding can be because sometimes
you write a script
and four years pass and you become a
different person in that time
and none of those things really make
sense and then okay you could go back
and rewrite but there's something
if you have an idea and you can have the
immediacy
of making it in that time it becomes a
full
thought instead of like this constant
broken up where you have to become like
you have to put down your artist hat and
you have to put on your producer hat and
you have to go in and you have to get
money and like that's fine it's all part
of the thing but it's distracting from
each other
so once you you can never get back on
the roll and so
it takes a while it takes a while it
takes much longer than people think
and you know in the meantime like
hopefully get some other jobs to
pay for your life and um and you keep
going
what were some of the notes you received
from the different investors that you
went to did they want you to change it
oh can you make her 30 years old instead
of four i mean like what
were some of the things they said to you
i don't care to talk about that i
i think everybody sure has a valid thing
but
until you know i have my own reasons and
i don't like when people give you notes
without asking you why
it doesn't make sense to me it's like oh
i don't like that
and you think well i could tell you why
that was the reason then we can really
have a discussion about it so
i think some people are better than
giving notes some people are absolutely
no
there are kind of maybes there's a lot
of waiting around for people to read
scripts and stuff like that so
you have to i say pick a group of people
maybe five
that you really trust who really know
you some of them can be in the film
industry some
hopefully ones like a dentist or
somebody works out of the industry or
something
to get the full spectrum of like
notes like i don't understand this why
does this happen and so i
instead of like people and people are
nice they ask can i read your script and
you get all excited about it because it
feels validating and then
you know but then you've subjected
yourself to 49 opinions where you don't
need 49 opinions you need five
so you know it's all about collaboration
i'm all about collaboration stuff but i
think it's uh
you have to be smart and
and also my advice would be be very very
very sure about your script
before you send it out because you
really only get one chance and that kind
of thing
unless you're like me and rewrote your
script but
so you just have to have patience you
have to have real conviction you know
and how long is your campaign 30 days 30
days okay
and is it correct that then if you make
your goal that it's being matched
i think i saw that on the side we have a
lot of yes we
we have matching goals we have matching
funds we have
you know this is very helpful to us in
many
many different ways so not just for the
money but for the attention
and for the aware and more attention but
the awareness that this is happening
like i was saying like i'm doing this
we're doing it this way get on board
you know and uh the trains leaving the
stage train's leaving the station you
need a ride get on board
you